folks if you listen to this long enough
you hear the show long enough and you
listen to the debt free screams long
enough you find there's two types of
people with money well there's a lot of
types of people but people fall largely
into two buckets there's the bucket of
people who are doing their debt-free
scream or someone like the young lady we
interviewed in our lobby just a few
minutes ago
they are happening to their money the
other bucket of people is the people the
money happens to them dr. Stephen Covey
used to say in his book the 7 Habits of
Highly Effective People the number one
habit of Highly Effective People is they
are proactive they happen to things
everything doesn't happen to them you
make the assumption that we can't
control all the external variables in
our life but we are largely in charge of
our own destiny or we stand back and
shake our head and wonder why everything
bad happens to us you either tell your
money what to do or you wonder where it
went
money flows from people who do not
manage it to the people who do manage it
if you take someone who manages money
well and as a result has become wealthy
and they lose everything they will
become wealthy again because the things
that made them wealthy that did not
leave when the money left and when you
take someone who does not manage money
well and they're given a pile of money
have you ever noticed they end up with
nothing because they don't happen to
their money their money happens to them
case in point lotto winners someone wins
the lottery the bankruptcy rate is
fourfold the national average four times
as likely to file bankruptcy if you win
the lottery as not isn't that
weird the vast majority of lotto winners
a decade later have nothing because the
very thing that caused them to play the
lotto in the first place is gives you an
indication that you're gonna lose it
why some athletes when they get money
end up with nothing
because they had the only skill they've
got it as athletic skill they had no
character no ability to manage the money
no ability to say no no ability to have
good relationships and boundaries those
are the things that lead you to build
wealth and so wealth it's an intentional
act now bad stuff can happen to people
and sometimes people are poor because
people are oppressing them I understand
that I'm not picking on the poor that's
not what I'm doing but what I am saying
is is that sometimes you're where you
are because of a series of decisions
you've made as a matter of fact usually
you're where you are then you can make
new decisions you don't have to well my
family the way I grew up in my
neighborhood my people those are how
sentences start when people are going to
explain why they're losing and it's not
their fault the little man can't get
ahead people like me you don't
understand about the isms that are out
there yeah I do
isms are real they're real but I mean
people every day who overcome their isms
sexism racism people overcome their isms
all the time
hard work hustle smarts looking forward
controlling the destiny is can everybody
do it apparently everybody can do it but
most people choose not to they choose
not to control the variables in their
life and so it comes down to something
as simple in personal finances doing a
budget when you do a budget it is you
exercising the fact that you believe you
control your destiny
if you're if you are a victim of destiny
why would you ever do a budget if you're
if you're gonna be controlled by an ism
if you're gonna be controlled by the way
you grew up if you're going to
contribute control but people in my
family people of my heritage people of
my ethnic background people of you fill
in the blank if you're going to be
controlled by that either so I grew up
on the other side of the tracks Dave
most millionaires did by the way the
vast majority of millionaires grew up on
the other side of the tracks the only
difference in them and the next-door
neighbor that's still on the other side
the tracks is they decided they didn't
want to live there so they picked their
bots up and they moved to the other side
of the tracks they lived like no one
else so that later they could live and
give like no one else
consequently we see things like the 5
million families that have been through
Financial Peace University you know what
the number one data point between them
being successful are the ones that are
successful going through that getting
out of debt and the ones that aren't the
number one data point is to do a budget
we can predict your success in Financial
Peace University by the second class
it's nine classes when you go through
nine lessons the second lesson we can
tell if you're going to be successful
did you come in with your zero based
budget done and every dollar the way we
teach you know I'm got my own version of
Dave Ramsey I've got my own version of
smart I'm ish I'm Dave Ramsey ish I'm
gonna do Financial Peace University ish
you're not gonna make it we can our data
I mean I mean people do something you
got good data okay we got good data we
know exactly who's gonna make it news
not we can study your behavior and tell
you if you keep on this path you are
going to fail and you've already started
down the wrong path so you got to turn
around and go back and start again the
people that do their every dollar budget
complete the class they typically
to all nine Lessons they stay in the
membership for a year continuing to
watch online they download the podcasts
they watch the debt-free screens on
YouTube to stay inspired to stay on
their budget how interesting
they were sick and tired of being sick
and tired they said I'm not gonna be
those people anymore I am going to
control these variables I'm going to
control my destiny do sometimes their
transmission go out just sometimes their
a car wreck is sometimes somebody get
cancer that sometimes somebody die yes
sometimes tragedy happens yes sometimes
I get laid off yes but guess what they
get up and do it again sometimes I get
knocked on their butt and they get back
up and they do it again and you get back
up and you do it again when you have a
plan and when you believe you're in
control of your destiny if you fall off
your budget you mess up you get back up
and you do it again you don't take the
every dollar app off your phone by the
way it's fairly easy to put back on
because it's free and you sit down there
and you do your budget the correlating
statistic between people that win at
anything and people that lose are those
that are intentional people that win are
intentional you don't accidentally win
the freaking Super Bowl
they never interview the guys at the end
of the Super Bowl go how'd you do that I
don't know man I just got off the bus I
just want to have no idea
now it's an intentional act of a decade
plus two decades usually of practice and
skill development that brought them of
that 10,000 hours of practice brought
them to that you don't accidentally play
a guitar like Brad Paisley it's not an
accident it's intentional act now some
of you got drunk and woke up married but
most people getting married is an
intentional act you date you court
you're very focused you do everything
right you smile at the right time and
you shave and take a bath and it causes
according to work and you get married
it's an intentional act you
at what your intentional with winning is
not accidental winning it money requires
budgeting there's no exception and you
don't get a pass because you're smart
the matter of fact if you're smart you
got to do it twice as much because you
think you're smart